protesters took to the streets of Hong
Kong beginning in April 20 1940 after
the Hong Kong government proposed a bill
permitting extradition to China since
then Hong Kong chief executive Carrie
Lam a position appointed by Beijing has
pledged to withdraw the bill but the
anti-government protests have evolved
past this issue and protesters are now
demanding more democratic freedoms in
Hong Kong honestly it's hard to see how
this will all end even if Carrie Lam
gets the boot that's probably not enough
to satisfy protesters and it seems
equally unlikely that Beijing will yield
to their demands the Chinese Communist
Party does not want to encourage similar
behavior and other regions problematic
to the regime the CCP also wants to show
Taiwan that the one country two systems'
formula works so far China has avoided a
Tiananmen style crackdown opting instead
for repressive police tactics the
Chinese President Xi Jinping has also
warned that anyone attempting to split
China would be crushed how the Communist
Party decides to ultimately address the
protests may change the course of
China's relationship with Hong Kong
forever which side do you think will
ultimately get its way let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI